I've always been interested in shooting
film rmax I always felt if they can
shoot for fiction film in that format
you'd get an incredibly immersive
experience Chris this is Harvey Dent
Rachel's to me everything about you
certainly
you'll still make who would be together
and you mean it don't make me your own
no one's ever done this before I felt
that shooting
sections of this film using IMAX
technology would give us the the biggest
possible canvas on which to keep telling
the story you see allocate simple taste
all you care about is money
as about sending a message
good evening ladies and gentlemen weird
lights entertaining but hello beautiful
a little fighting you
I like that IMAX is the absolute highest
resolution you can achieve it really
takes you back to being a little kid
watching a film it's just larger than
life
some men aren't looking for anything
logical the car people bullied recently
or negotiated with some men just one of
those stubborn see now we don't have to
become to stop men like him know your
limits Mouse the way that man has no
limits
it is really an extraordinary experience
to see a large action sequence on the
IMAX screen and really just knocks you
out of your seat
Knight is guarding this just before the
dawn
the gun is coming
why do you want to kill me I don't wanna
kill you
what'd I do without you
or you live long enough to see yourself
become the villain here we go
I'm not sure you're very loud enough sir